[Music]
we're delighted to unveil new native
integrations between vertex ai and
bigquery ml around model deployment
model registry and machine learning
pipelines
what's bigquery ml you might ask with
your big data in bigquery the data
warehouse on google cloud bigquery ml
enables you to build machine learning
models directly using sql from logistic
regression to xgboost and more
bqml makes it easy to train and make
predictions on vast amounts of data
without needing to set up any extra
infrastructure for training or batch
predictions what about vertex ai vertex
ai integrates ml offerings across google
cloud into a seamless development
experience from deploying model
endpoints to model monitoring automl to
custom models ml apis to ml pipelines
vertex ai is there to support all your
end-to-end machine learning workflows
so the latest integrations between bqml
and vertex ai give you the best of both
worlds
with the newly launched vertex ai model
registry you can train your models using
bqml register them to vertex ai model
registry and then view and manage all
your models in one place with version
control and metadata tagging built in
vertex ai model registry also makes it
easier for you to deploy your models
trained in bigquery ml for real-time
predictions and if you want to automate
your entire training to development
pipeline you can set up vertex ai
pipelines using the new official
bigquery and bqml operators to help you
execute any query
including training and deploying bqml
models as part of your pipeline let's
take a quick look at how this can help
you out imagine you're training a model
based on text data stored in bigquery
and you want to predict whether the
topic of each document is related to a
particular topic of interest so you want
to train a binary classifier after
experimenting with different models
you've settled on a model that you want
to use and register on model registry so
you add model registry equals vertex ai
to your model creation query in bigquery
ml
once the model has finished training you
can go to vertex ai model registry to
see your model
on model registry we can see all our
models in a single place whether they're
trained with bqml or other methods like
automl or custom trained next we can
deploy the model to an endpoint directly
from model registry we can give the
endpoint a name choose the compute
resources needed for serving online
predictions and voila it's ready to
prepare the endpoint now we'll test it
and great
it's able to give us real-time
predictions
but what if you'd like to execute all of
these steps together as a pipeline
with the new bigquery and bqml operators
you can quickly execute all your steps
from training to deployment strung
together as one pipeline that's the
power of vertex ai pipelines you can
automate and track the entire model life
cycle of your bqml models so there you
have it the best of both worlds native
integration between vertex ai and bqml
allows developers to have the best of
both worlds ml pipelines with multiple
options for training and all the data
you could need
check out the links in the description
below to get started with vertex ai and
bqml try out yourself today free of
charge
[Music]
you